well hello there reject nation
greg and john here today and we're gonna
do a
podcast spoiler talk for wonder woman
1984 a movie
that john and i have not talked one
second about together nope this will be
a reaction reaction
a movie just from looking all over
social media
people either hate this movie or love
this movie
all we can do is just be very honest
about our opinions i have
literally no clue how john feels about
this film i don't think
john knows how i feel so i have an
inkling
from a couple scraps of scene around the
internet on twitter and stuff yeah
but uh yeah so this is gonna be a q a
style what that basically means is like
you guys submitted some questions
and we're gonna do our review mainly
based off that it's most of the
questions are about maxwell lord and
cheetah so we'll get to those pretty
quick and then some other ones and
there's some other things that we just
want to talk about ourselves as well but
let's kick it off because all we can
really do right now is just be
very honest with you guys about our
feelings first question of the day
crawler g07 how did you feel about the
movie do you think it's better
than the first one i like the movie but
i think the first one is a little bit
better
i thought it was the best dc movie and
the worst one of course simultaneously
anything you say honestly is correct
honestly yeah they got it so right
and what were they thinking oh my god oh
my god i was so faithful to the comics
and i didn't know what was going on
there's nothing like the source material
i i personally i thought that the first
one was
miles better i thought it was way way
better the first one but i don't want to
spend this whole talk
comparing it because i think a lot of
the time you know when you see people
who are especially ones who are getting
mad at people who are hating on the
movie i've noticed there's the
the common argument of you guys just
expected to be like the first one
or you guys just couldn't accept that
this was a more bright colorful
light-hearted film
none of that was a surprise like you see
the trailers i know
this was in fact i don't think this
movie was mis-marketed i don't think
this movie was mispromoted
in fact i'm like no this is pretty akin
to what we got in the trailer
i was expecting a brighter more
lighthearted more colorful film i wasn't
expecting something to feel
like the first one so that actually
wasn't an issue
for me overall the execution i'm
honestly right now at a point of
i don't really know if i sway more to
liking this movie you're not liking this
movie i think there's a lot of
problems some very apparent ones there
are like isolated
scenes and moments and incidences there
are things about it that i really do
like a lot
overall i'm i'm really confused i
i think i currently
sway a little bit more towards the not
really liking it there's parts i really
enjoyed though so
we'll see maybe by the end of this talk
i'll probably have a clear-cut
idea where i ultimately land on the
movie because yeah there's a lot of pros
and there's a lot of cons and i just
can't tell right now if the cons are
currently just outweighing the pros for
me
because i can wake up tomorrow and be
like you know what though those pros
really do shine and i do
care more about those in the cons yeah
yeah uh
currently i'm in a sort of place where i
feel like my feelings could evolve or
change especially pending this
conversation
generally liked it i mean i definitely i
think came down more on the positive
side than not i do think that yeah there
are some
definite things that this movie maybe
stumbles over or misses out on because
it's trying to do
maybe a couple too many other things um
but yeah i
generally liked the direction and i
thought that
funny enough this kind of did a reverse
for me whereas like i
the first wonder woman movie impacted me
quite a bit and on a structural level i
actually thought that
movie's first two thirds were really
solid and then there were issues i have
with the
final act whereas this was the reverse i
thought the first two thirds had a lot
of stuff that was cool in them and were
kind of loose
in ways and then once it got to act
three i was like okay finally i'm
i'm really feeling a lot of the stuff
this movie wants me to feel
so i think in that respect i did come
out
ultimately feeling like it may be a bit
of a shaky landing but it's a landing
but that's my point is like you make a
good point there because
the movie to me you could always feel
that it was going somewhere it was
building to something and by the time it
got it got
better as it went along i can't say it
for every part of the movie which will
be the very next question
but most of it i thought especially in
terms of getting more wrapped up in the
emotional beats
i thought it as it progressed it got
better so i would
i would agree with that statement
overall i mean i would agree with that
but let's move on here
when i put my post out on the community
page this was easily the most talked
about one
so aaron r you've been selected to give
the overall thoughts here
tell me about your thoughts on cheetah's
transformation
well i thought she was
really the weakest part of this whole
movie yeah
i don't really i like kristen wick
generally speaking i didn't really care
for her performance here i thought the
writing of her
was very underdeveloped it really did
just start feeling like amazing
spider-man 2 to me like
yes it has the similar traits of
characters like syndrome from the
incredibles
uh riddler from batman forever the
obsessed fan who wants more
and when
when she had the line i want to be an
apex
predator i was
like what where is this coming from
the food chain basically it makes no
sense
what are you talking about the ark
itself just doesn't make sense to me
she says i want to be more confident so
she basically wants to be loved and
appreciated by
humans by other people so she starts
getting what she wants
everything about her arc was the most
cliche
comic book way it could have ever
unfolded some people
really love her but i do find her
discussion discussion around cheetah to
be the most divisive
and i do fall on the side of i do not
like what they did with her here when
she says the apex prayer line i just
started reflecting on the whole arc of
her character how it made no sense she
wishes to be like diana to be loved to
be wanted to be
appreciated have confidence all these
things and she starts getting all that
she starts getting the adoration and
then suddenly she's like
[ __ ] humans yeah yeah i want nothing to
do with them
she gets completely suckered by
maxwell's whole thing about right you
know
why would i want more except we don't
really get to know her character
anywhere near enough to
drive the motivation yeah of that beyond
the more
petty angles of i want people to like me
and i want to be popular you know i want
to be accepted in society
so yeah where does this maniacal turn
come from other than i guess
just the chaos around i felt like the
movie was trying to set it up
that the sacrifice of the monkey paw
effect what
diana was saying is that oh what she's
losing is the good in her the humanity
yeah i felt like they were really trying
to emphasize that so that way when she
says her apex predator line it becomes
cheetah that's why she lost humanity
well i think that phrase has been thrown
around a lot in the popular discourse
especially in our politics here so that
might have also been a grab to be
topical too
fair enough um i did think the cheetah
effects were
there i like the close-up practical ones
uh way more than i did the cgi ones
but in terms of like the fight and the
moment there i just felt
absolutely nothing i felt nothing
towards that moment and
it felt so shoehorn you can't help but
rewrite it in your head i think a lot of
us did people who are not even
like involved in editing or writing
we're probably doing it ourselves of
you know it would have been really good
if you just had her here barbara minerva
and then she becomes cheetah in the
third one
that would have been way more effective
in terms of what they did here i did
start getting
spider-man 3 amazing spider-man 2 um
symptoms uh with her character overall i
just i was not a fan
yeah it definitely marks something i
think the movie was trying to maybe do
too much with especially
when you weigh it against some of the
stuff with chris pine i feel like the
movie kind of
set up this female friendship which is
something kind of new to see on screen
in this capacity and i thought they
could have made something dramatic out
of that and yeah developed
barbara more so that when she makes her
turn it it breaks our hearts more and i
did like a lot of what kristen wiig did
but i feel like yeah the script the one
consistent thing i kept griping about
throughout the movie is
oh that's right she's in this her
character
is gonna come back at some point and
yeah she only really serves
to be a physical foil and to you know
kind of slow down diana's path and
i think every you know theme that's
brought up through her character could
have been
way better explored i think that cheetah
is one of her biggest arch nemesis and
some people might go out there and say
that
she's equivalent to like joker for
batman so to kind of make her secondary
villain on that note is kind of a
lackluster disappointing effect and just
a victim of the circumstance of a bigger
villain you know and i do
think that there was so much potential
to make her
a wonderful bill even in this movie
there was opportunity within the script
i thought where they could have made
some great
moments of debate yeah some great
moments yeah i could give this up but
why do you get to keep this diana
how come you're the one if i re retract
my wish
how come you get to still have your
powers and stuff just because you were
born with this
but yet i don't there could have been so
many interesting
arguments to be had but it's just kind
of one note and there's a lot of
feelings that could have come out of it
if they had developed their friendship
beyond that one
dinner lunch that they could get to you
know because again they i thought they
had promising chemistry i thought there
was a lot of missed opportunity and uh
overall wasn't a fan
but i do want to talk about a part where
i was a fan
segway and that's in the next part
galaxy eyes pd
what did you think of pedro pascal's
maxwell lore character and his arc
he is the best part of the movie
absolutely undoubtedly he is the best
part of the movie
i loved everything he did he hit the
right
note you immediately thinking of some
for me i was thinking oh yeah kind of
like a patrick bateman 1980s xs type of
character
american psycho vibe about him but then
you find out that oh this is really just
a front this is a mass that he puts on
because he's a guy really in a lot of
pain and i thought that was like a
pretty
bold choice to make for your main
villain
to bring him a lot of humanity but every
single layer of maxwell lord and i loved
watching pedro pascal just slowly
lose his sanity over the course of the
movie and just
fall apart like if it he brought so much
physically to a role that where you
might not expect it and more than just
the makeup of the eye
and the sweat like yeah his nerves are
just shaking
like talking to the president he's just
trying to keep it all together and he is
the embodiment of
of excess and more and i didn't know it
until this movie but i think donald
trump's a bad
guy oh and what i think donald trump's
are bad i think movie fighters
wait a minute there's delusions to trump
in this movie where
next you're gonna tell me like a wall
pops up somewhere during the film
i like i was watching it going i think
donald trump's bad oh
no like some entertainer guy who's like
you know full of it but tries to swindle
everyone around him and convince them of
more but really he's not selling them
anything and then some random stroke of
luck
sends him up the ladder wow wow i
wouldn't have thought of it
i did not draw the parallel until the
credits started rolling no
until they until they put that
dedication to like thank you to donald
trump and his pictures and their credits
that's the big credit scene as they
thank him for the inspiration directly
yeah it's pretty obvious on there it was
a little little on the nose there
with the trumpism yeah and i don't think
it's because
everyone depending on who's president
often that
if there's a president in a movie or
some character like that
we go oh this is a reflection of like
bush there's a reflection of clinton
this is a reflection of that i don't
think it's
audience projection onto it i think it's
pretty apparent
yeah it's definitely made to uh
harmonize with our times and and
create dissonance with our times too
although i honestly didn't get too
distracted by that during the movie i
wasn't sitting there going
ah they're beating me over the head with
trumpisms like i i get it and the
movie's also about
truth or lack thereof i mean he's not
do he's not doing a trump impression
there are things about him and there's
more to him than that i mean he cares
about his child
you know yeah he cares about alistair
that's the one thing about his arc this
is what i mean i'm kind of back and
forth because it was so predictable and
the reason it was so predictable that it
was going to go that route
was because the kid's not a character
oh he's just like he's dropped any
dialogue
big neon sign pointing at that character
like every time he's on screen just
picture pascal does not shut the [ __ ] up
and he just keeps talking while this kid
never gets any luck i was half
expecting his wish to be some dialogue
and development as a character and then
you sit there going well is that a
detractor or is this just a
illustration of how unconcerned with the
kids actual feelings and well-being the
character
uh max lord is you know i mean i felt
like right away he really cares about
his kid yeah it was
it it wasn't some you know disney thing
of i want to work
forget you son but you really seem like
he cared about his kid but it did remind
me of that in a sense because it is like
i'm working my ass off and i'm running
this operation that's clearly not on the
up and up and you know that desperate
father
energy is there yeah i don't know how i
really
felt about its overall conclusion i want
to get more into the script later
because of
how it pertains to maxwell lord in in
the handling of the execution
but if we're talking solely about his
arc pedro pascal and that was one of the
moments that brought me to tears
even though i could give two shits about
this kid i was like man but
that dude when you put him with a child
that picture basketball
will bring you to tears man yeah
absolutely and yeah i thought his
performance was terrific he really sold
everything especially the makeup like
the worst
physically he looks his performance is
right in line with that and i feel like
you could easily cross into chewing on
scenery and i thought he
managed to have fun with this but also
yeah give it a really compelling
performance and whenever he
was on screen whatever the situation
were some of the times i was
most engaged and involved you know and i
like that they went with a villain
that isn't as clear-cut as just like ah
you know i'm gonna come in and destroy
the city it's it's a more
appealing and insidious operation
especially with how it lures everyone on
earth in which i thought was really
clever like the
the actual mechanics of his character
aside in terms of the sci-fi stuff
just his motivations and what he grew
into i really appreciated and that was a
nice contrast from the previous movie
because
you know when ares is revealed it's a
bit like oh okay he's a big bad guy we
gotta fight now
yeah and so this was a bit different and
had more ideology so i appreciated that
i think it would have been better for
this maxwell
lord and uh if it was just maxwell lord
as the main villain and he didn't have
cheetah
yeah and every time he was on screen i
could care less about anyone else
what is this guy gonna do all right
let's move on so we got steve trevor now
to talk about
we got a couple of questions here i'm
gonna lead with this one first
steve's return was it really necessary
from wesley
here's where i'm so conflicted on the
steve trevor and and diana prince stuff
it goes without saying their chemistry
is still top-notch chris pine is still
so damn great in the role
undoubtedly but i did find myself going
why am i not
caring that much about him being here
don't get me wrong that moment where
and i want to talk a little bit about
gal gadot in between all this too
that moment where he does you know
finally convince diana like you gotta
let me go
you gotta let me go again you know and
then when she's walking away i thought
the way that was executed was wonderful
like she's crying you're feeling the
intensity of it
i started getting misty-eyed i wasn't
like swelling with tears but i started
getting misty out of the situation
you catch his final words to her before
she says i love you back like it's a
good yeah
especially when you have subtitles on on
hbo max makes it a lot easier to like
really pick up on all that and it was a
really great scene and i thought both of
them really knocked it out of the park
in that moment but overall
was where i had some issues and i think
i finally pinpointed why i wasn't really
caring as much
is because he's not a real character in
this movie
he's someone who doesn't have an arc
he's just kind of there
he he shows up like what am i doing here
i need to find out what brought me here
i shouldn't be here
that's his whole art yeah he doesn't
feel all that
integral to it so while they're doing
the flipparoo of the fish out of water
with like wow look at the 80s freaking
weird if you compare it to the first one
that is still driving the plot forward
where she is about like she she has a
very specific idea of what humanity is
and then she's like getting thrusted
into this world
where she kind of thinks she's better
than everyone and then when she's
viewing humanity she's like wow this is
beautiful it's like emotional and moving
where here is just kind of funny and
sometimes i thought like the jokes kind
of felt a little flat even the
especially that montage moment
with the trying on clothes i was like
man this is going on way too long
this is not funny this looked funnier in
the trailer yeah this was really funny
in the trailer but damn i was
fine with this being a deleted scene
like
with the pacing it's not really working
so i didn't find his character
all that necessary for here because he's
not a real character he doesn't really
have
an arc to go through whereas in the
first one he really both of them do and
their story lines work like that we're
here
they don't that's where my conflict is i
like chris pine
i like their chemistry man i like that
final scene with them together
but overall it just didn't feel all that
essential for him to be in here yeah
and i think it's got at least for me
because i've been chewing on this partly
to do with the way they introduce him
because they
kind of set up an immediate set of
stakes and also an immediate idea as to
what the resolution will be when he
shows up and i thought it was cool that
they kept this very
raps in the trailer but you know they
introduced him he's looking in the
mirror realizing
he's a different person he's in a
different person's body the second that
happens i feel like at least in my brain
i was going uh okay this cannot this
just
isn't going to last it can't um and so i
feel like if you had maybe
saved that twist made it a twist and
saved it for later or
some kind of thing i don't know exactly
how that would work but i feel like it
might have at least
lulled you in a little bit better than
going oh already here's an explanation
for how this is working that we can also
see a direct exit out of
yeah you know and so yeah and it makes
that moment at the end between her and
the other guy cute and stuff but
ultimately yeah i i liked their scenes
while they were on
but when he disappears yeah he doesn't
really factor into anything with max
lord or
anything with cheetah yeah and so yeah
and
i kind of felt like there were some
things
i appreciated kind of humanizing gal
gadot a little bit more here
like before steve showed up she really
sold
that loneliness quality to her i thought
she did an
excellent job on that and i thought her
performance here was pretty strong
there were parts where i was kind of in
conflict of i feel like she would have
drawn the conclusion
of i'm gonna have to let this i'm gonna
let you go not
not steve trevor yeah telling me to do
it and then i just started getting out
of my own head
in certain parts during this movie and
this is a really personal subjective
thing all i can do is be honest you mean
to tell me
this iconic independent female warrior
woman
what does this say about people who
really because i know some people who
have like
lost their boyfriends like who have died
or their husbands who have died in 45
years or something
and she's still so hung up on this yeah
that she can't move on
the fact that she doesn't make the choi
like there's power in that but then i
also get kind of pulled out of
but you're also wonder woman is this
uniquely you've had a lot of life
experiences and you can't get over it
this feels uniquely like a situation you
would much earlier be able to see
the workings of and be able to realize
that you're
earlier on than she does that you're
gonna have to let this go versus the
like 45 years in the making here of all
these experiences
yeah it doesn't really convince you that
this can last or that it is
natural in any way and i also did have
some issues with the fact that it wasn't
her concluding here it was
the soul of steve trevor telling her to
do that because i felt like wonder woman
would do it
here's my real thing that was
distracting me and the ponderer brought
this question up and it was a
major distraction the entire time i was
watching it
which is how do you feel about the fact
that diana and steve use another man's
body to have sex without his consent
okay everything about this was so
distracting to me
because when they first do it i'm like
oh they're kind of that hunt for red
october thing where like oh he's not
really speaking russian yeah i mean he's
speaking russian he's not he's
but they're bullying in english i'm like
oh so he's in a different guy's body and
then there are
issues like yes the sexual part like
it's like to me it didn't read as cute
when the guy shows up because i'm like
dude does this guy have any recollection
that diana like totally
is okay though because she's super hot
and she's wondering
so he should be please right you should
be so excited right now bro you should
ask for a number on the spot like to me
it was kind of funny
because i'm like well you get funny but
then there's also the other context so
well you kind of took advantage of this
guy's body
and what about the people in his life
and right
the other part to me was like you you
guys seem to show no concern for taking
over this guy's body and stealing his
clothes
not one conversation of this debate was
look i just can't take over this guy's
body this is not right i can't
i can't i can't live like this this is
wrong to do this to this person whoever
he is
it's messed up no one says that they
could care less
he's insignificant you're steve trevor
and i'm wonder woman and for a while i
was wondering if
how much she could tell or not because
there's a piece of dialogue where
they at least acknowledge it together
but i was like did she know immediately
or did you have to break this news i
wish i could have seen that part
i could see it within uh diana's
character too though to see
past the physicality just to see within
the soul so actually
i will give the movie credit that you
know like in other works of
film or whatever i might be distracted
by that like what the guy doesn't look
like steve trevor is a totally different
guy but with diana prince
i'd like no she could see she could see
past the physicality and see the soul
of steve trevor so i i appreciated that
approach
but there's all this other context
around there and i'm like this movie
couldn't give two shits about
acknowledging it again without taking
that
further than it goes and without
exploring it deeper than it goes it does
become one of these areas where
you're like i'm parts this is really
charming but also i don't know how this
fits overall
yeah so i'm like i'm really back and
forth it's one of those things i like
chris pine i like steve trevor
that's why i enjoy it when it's there
but i didn't have anywhere near the
the level of effect i was hoping it
would have and i ultimately didn't find
his presence to be 100 necessary
does it go to serve the themes of not
cheating in life
of dealing with reality and learning to
appreciate the truth in the moment of
today and wanting what you do have
yeah does it go to serve that yes but he
is also a main character in here
and ultimately as a character journey he
doesn't feel all that essential
no that feels like a note yeah we get
steve can we figure out a way to get
steve back in there people left steve
last time it kind of does and now i'm
like what are we gonna do for part of
three when they want steve back are we
gonna just leave flashbacks are we gonna
resurrect them again we're done with
steve trevor
all right so the next one we got on this
is a man named rocky what did you think
about the overall direction
of the writing i'm gonna slightly change
your question to be direction and
writing just so we can cover a lot of
bases here
there's a lot of more specific questions
that we have more to go through in a bit
but we'll give some basic thoughts i
never could get behind it since it all
felt kind of
messy uh yeah i mean that is a big part
of my conflict with this movie
is it got better as it went i do think
the writing
really was not that great i thought it
was
just in the first five minutes of this
movie i'm like god damn
you're really hammering in the themes
here as much as
possible that page five state
so first we start off with the narration
from diana yeah and then we're going to
start off with going to connie neos and
talking about
more themes and then we're going to end
it with more things and we're going to
show you a depiction of the theme
before doing it again for the whole
thing
and every time we talk about the memes
we're gonna take the art part out of the
dialogue
and that's a big part of what kind of
hindered some of the maxwell lord scenes
too
in terms of the finale moment i love
that they did do the reveal of she's
really talking to all the people you
know because at first i'm like man this
is
way over this you're really over doing
it with your motivational speech you're
trying to maybe just cool your heart
on that sleeve there but then when you
realize she's talking to all the people
like all right all right i'll let it go
all right
yeah she's talking to everyone she's
gotta talk to the world you gotta be
expositional here
in this moment you know so that that did
click that did make sense
um but overall i thought the writing it
was very
not subtle and but here's where i go
back and forth with the movie in terms
of the direction because the ret
direction and writing combines i feel
like they really go hand in hand in this
movie at times it really did feel like i
was watching an 80s movie
i didn't know where
that was like oh it feels messy and
faulty because it's portraying
an 80s movie because it wasn't like an
80s
tribute movie you know they didn't
there's like no 80s music in here
they don't do any of those things like
they make fun of the 80s there's a
difference when you see something like
stranger things which is like look at
the eight look how
crazy it is you know i'm talking i
forgot this was in the 80s half the time
yeah yeah i mean it's worth dealing with
more of the the things that were the
the resonance of fear during the 80s and
the problems during the 80s
more than it is about highlighting the
cool 80s
side you know the nostalgia of that so
when they were capturing the movie there
were times where
i was like this does feel like a movie i
would have seen in the 80s
not a movie that is paying tribute to
the 80s yeah
i don't know if i'm clear about it but i
hope you guys get what i'm saying so
there were times where
with the way it was scripted the way it
was directed
and especially with certain cgi moments
that did not
click with me where i was like but is
this intentional i can't tell if it's
if it's intentional i'll i'll be way
more accepting of it
but there are times where i'm like i i
don't know if this is intentional
and that's where i thought it was kind
of tonally all over the place and pacing
wise too
because i thought there were too many
characters i thought there was too much
story going on
i didn't really have enough time to
really
feel for a lot of what was happening
there was a lot of intermittence yeah
because i would find that occasionally a
scene would happen where i'm like oh
dang they're actually allowing this
scene to breathe and i think that's one
of the benefits of the run time is while
there's a lot happening in this movie
i've seen a lot of other movies where
more is happening in the same amount of
time and it feels even more disjointed
so i feel like the the direction
i liked more than the writing i thought
it at least did a lot to keep the energy
going it had a lot of those earmarks of
the 80s especially when you're
like in the mall a lot of those like
moving dolly shots and like you're
looking
over the rails and things like i thought
the energy was
there and yeah the writing was this
inconsistent thing where
every time they wanted to talk about the
themes it would peel back the artifice
it felt kind of frankensteiny or like i
was flipping through
a graphic novel where like all of a
sudden there are a few pages from a
different story here and then there are
a few pages from this other story here
and so like yeah there are a bunch of
isolated moments and scenes and themes i
liked with pretty much
every character and i feel like
everything was there in this movie
and yeah ultimately it comes down to
there's just certain things that aren't
developed as well as they could be or
again the script is trying to
juggle certain things where again
especially with barbara minerva doesn't
feel very interested
in developing her beyond some of the
more
broadly reaching things like with being
harassed and stuff like that they're a
bit more
universal and that diana is also subject
to
yeah so yeah it's a movie with a lot on
its mind that i really admired
i do appreciate that it spent a lot more
like it
breathed like a film to me in the sense
that it didn't seem like they were
economically plopping action sequences
in so it's like there's a lot about what
this movie was going
for in terms of its shape that i do
appreciate
and think is a good step in the right
direction but
overall it's it's a real mixed bag of
execution
i would the action scene stuff i i kind
of agree and i kind of disagree
because what i really noticed is i
didn't
let's take the i forget which part of
the middle east they went to
wherever the car chase one car chase
scene was okay
when they're trying to get maxwell lord
and the choreography of it
other than like some weird slow-mo
running shots of gal gadot where she
just looks
dead on the inside fast running is not
an easy
you know those like close-up ones on her
yeah like that does not look good
yeah you don't look like you're engaged
in this activity
but the at the action scenes i thought
the choreography and i thought it was
exciting and i thought it really was
cool to look at
i thought it was like yeah this is good
yet i
noticed the emotional weight of the
action scenes none of them were really
felt and you can't help but compare that
to the first wonder woman i think
this is a part two after all when you
think about action scenes in the first
wonder woman
there's so much more emotional resonance
to them whereas here i did find myself
going
this is this choreography wise visual
this is really cool but yet there's a
missing tension
and there's a missing stakes and there's
a missing emotional drive here
that i'm not really feeling in any of
the action scenes i mean especially with
the barbara minerva cheetah fight which
was one that i felt like
this is the reason cheetah is here
exactly physical fight yeah
and that is one drawback to a less
physical villain you know the action
looks cool the mall fight was a little
jarring in the way it was captured but
it felt like a superman movie or
something like it felt like a classic
superhero movie to me so i i get with
what they were going for there the
invisible jet scene yeah
i like this you know what i enjoy saying
i'm so back and forth on almost every
scene here
because because one of the issues i
really have with the script is it's one
of the most convenience driven plots
i've ever seen in a movie
everything is so conveniently placed for
them at like right down and maxwell lord
showing up to the president to be like
what's what's all this
what did i just stumble on you did you
create a way to get exactly what i
needed
what is this this is ideal where they
show up at the plane like
nobody's here full of fuel enough to get
you all these guys
who are suddenly being attentive now
that you've turned the plane on
yeah i'm like oh why is this plane full
of gas here on the runway and it's just
enough to get them across
no it was ready to go out in the morning
there was a lot of those scenes there
was a lot
in this movie where it's just
conveniently placed
for them everything is just conveniently
placed that
kind of trope does bother me when it's
like there's lack of investigation
or lack of problem solving you don't
feel like you're earning the deductions
and you're earning the next step of the
adventure yeah
and uh you know i think a lot of it
tries to be forgiven by its tone of like
no it is more of a fun light-hearted one
which it is
like i said it gets heavy i'm so back
and forth on so much of it like bathroom
boys
he's asking did you feel it was
incomplete somehow
when i finished watching i felt like
something was missing but i can't place
it and i
left with that feeling of the film of i
don't get this
this movie's two and a half hours long
and yet
i i constantly am left with this feeling
of
i i want i wanted a little bit more
emotional resonance out of almost
every plot point here it's weird
i sat there relishing in the emotional
resonance that was there and being like
these scenes are good but yeah like at
the totality of the movie you are like i
wish they had
focused on this and maybe had taken some
plot points out or some distractions out
and i think
that's partly what it is there are some
great scenes but now i'm thinking back
and i'm like this invisible jet moment
as cool as i thought that was and as
touching as i thought aspects of that
scene were i don't really think it
helps or adds anything the plane
disappears
and it never disappears and it and like
i said it's another convenient moment
because there's nothing foreshadowing
the fact that she's been learning this
ability yeah
she's just like convenience i've been
learning inability first time i'm ever
gonna like the lines were funny
of like cup of coffee and i couldn't
find it again like that's a funny line
but then the fact that she just happens
to like okay i could buy it
it's just such a convenient moment part
of it too for me was i feel like they
did something so nice in creating a
villain and a threat that is bigger than
one person and that does start to
suck in the whole world and one thing i
appreciated was that they did at least
at points
clue you into like how much this is
affecting the citizens and also playing
on their desires
and i feel like the movie does in some
ways slight itself by taking diana kind
of away from all that and putting her
like you need a personal story for her
to contend with but again splitting that
attention between
barbara and uh steve trevor i think also
kind of
hampers some of the potential that that
could have brought to the overall
scenario as well as the maxwell lord
scenario and to the overall theme so
that when every time you check in on the
theme it doesn't have to be so
on the nose yeah skywalker 501 first
as asking what did you guys think of the
movies classic christopher's superman
fuel that pat jenkins was going for
i mean yeah she really doubled down for
like she was very obvious that the first
wonder woman
she there's a there's a scene that's
clearly
from the first superman movie and then
here that
immediately allowed me to be a little
bit more forgiving for certain parts so
i'm like okay i get what she's going for
like especially just with the first
title smash of wwe 84.
like oh yeah it feels like a superman
movie right away but
here we go again there are times where i
thought it
really worked matter of fact i was off
i loved i loved the whole thing with her
learning how to do aerial movements uh
be in the sky use the weather like i
like how that came back
with steve trevor talking about the
ability of flight it's all about
feeling yeah and i really love that and
there were some of the cgi where i
thought it looked pretty good other
times a little off but in terms
of the emotional context of it i very
much loved
how they did that and that's how she
like finds where cheetah and maxwell
lower heart i just zip it through the
sky i'm like
don't you have the power to get an
invisible jet where'd you put that
clearly you weren't visible while you
were sitting in it so it would be a very
effective tool
and apparently it's quieter that way
faster to go
i don't know but then there were times
where i'm like okay this is some parts
that start feeling like superman too
that's fine so you're meant to not a bad
movie you know especially with her
and like spiderman who does it too uh
where she's like losing some of her
powers and i
i thought that was a really good element
to include in here because it does
raise the stakes where you know like i
did find more attention in that white
house scene because i'm like oh [ __ ] she
could get injured
even though the rules are kind of on and
off again here once you have this
restriction this is a slow release
uh drawback to this wish there were
times where i slow released monkey ball
but then there are times it starts
feeling like superman 3 and superman 4.
i'm like oh [ __ ]
why are you starting to feel like the
bad superman movie beat them all
tribute to everyone it started feeling
like all the superman movies
including the bad ones and uh that's
where
thematically i'm like oh i'm not sure
i'm not sure there are times where it
really clicks
and there are times where it starts
smelling like some of the bad ones yeah
let me skip ahead to this one really
quick since we've been kind of touching
on it
was brown eyed black she was asking was
the golden armor required
oh god you know the introduction of that
scene first off was just like of course
like the way it was handled just like
the weakest script
storytelling of for of the most i mean
we've seen the trailer you know it's
going to come into play but if you
haven't seen the trailer you're like
well she's definitely wearing that in a
little bit
what's this gold you mean this random
flashback of mythology
that's central to themscare and culture
didn't just flow right into the movie
well it probably would have been cooler
if that was your opening scene
yeah yeah if you did that opening scene
first and add more at stake it would
have been cooler
so i wasn't a fan of how they introduced
that i will talk about the we will talk
about the post-credits scene later
because i felt that
made it better the post-credits scene
yeah and when she uses the golden armor
by the time she's using it
see from watching the trailer and then
the movie just telling you that she's
gonna be wearing this at some point in
the movie
and the fact that she was losing her
powers i started going
that smart okay yeah because she's not
gonna be as strong
so she's gonna need the golden armor
suit to take on
cheetah and maxwell lord like she's
gonna need this suit
but then she gets her powers back
and and the suit doesn't really amount
to much i mean
she she protects herself with the wings
for a little bit and then
[ __ ] this this is unnecessary you know
what let's just go with good
old-fashioned physics and get some
electricity going in here and that
should do the trick
and i guess that won't affect me at all
i mean yeah i guess that's what
protected her in the water
i suppose but no i'm gonna be a
conductor but overall
right but overall the golden armor
the fact that she got her powers back
already so that's where the conflict
comes in because it would have just been
a double beat from the first movie to
this if
she let go of steve trevor at the very
end again then it would have just been
like well that's what they did in wonder
woman one so the fact that they placed
it earlier in this movie
was smart in terms that way you're not
just drawing the exact comparison it's
feeling different from the first wonder
woman movie the double beat
of saying goodbye is not as apparent or
obvious
with that though because she gets her
powers back already suddenly it's like
what the [ __ ] do you need the golden
armor
yeah exactly and i feel like for
something as significant as that it
really starts like the second it turned
up in the movie i had this thought of
like really
you're gonna use it for this and i don't
want to you know spend too much time on
what i would have done but
they set it up as this thing that
protected
this you know original warrior from just
a
horde of souls yeah and so i was
thinking to myself partly
during that i was like oh yeah if the
world's going crazy you know maybe this
is a protective measure like she doesn't
want to strike out against all these
innocent people who are falling prey to
this maybe this will lead to some kind
of very powerful just active i'm just
going to protect myself from the
circumstances as i go find the source
but yeah it ultimately just turns into a
clever or just a
plot-oriented way to make
up for the earlier stakes of her not
having her powers and then yeah
it's it's weird it looked like it would
be such a triumphant moment and that was
actually kind of some of my least
favorite action
was with that suit and the way it was
you know just sort of used
yeah oh well let's move on here chase
gardner what did you guys think of the
ending theme of giving up the things you
want most in life to make the hard
decision to make things better in your
own life and the closest
people around you i feel like you found
a very clear-cut theme
the theme isn't uh like to me
the message and theme was kind of like
like a whole lot of things
you gotta live in and accept the truth
and
uh make the most out of your reality in
your present moment yeah you know
appreciate the things that you do have
more is not always more i mean
the thing with with this question i feel
like this is a pretty good boiler point
of it
yeah look of course i like the theme
yeah of course it's a great i like what
absolutely how much of an [ __ ] would
i be like screw that
you should have she should have kept
steve around fantasy for everyone next
we'll look at
whatever he wanted so unrealistic stupid
just
wish things into reality and never grow
i mean that's that's a big part of what
i i liked about because
at one point max belord is kind of
touching on things of you know
especially especially living out in
places like la where they're really big
on things like law of attraction and all
that
positive thinking but there's also the
difference of wishful thinking
where all you gotta do is think about it
and uh then i should be able to get it
you know that's not what that's really
all about very it's not
want driven which this character very
much is like to me
maxwell lord felt like a tails from the
[ __ ] kind of tail yeah it felt like it
was
that sort of thing of like oh yeah you
get this great thing but you start
taking advantage and there's this tragic
element to it that he and he could have
just fallen to his ultimate demise out
of excess and power
yeah i like the ending note of what they
did with him like if it wasn't such an
obvious arc that they were headed to
from the kids first scene
that probably would have hit better i
was moved to tears at that point
uh it would have hit better if in terms
of the theme what they explored
that was the an issue that i kind of
have with it though i feel like they
really needed to be
very expositional so we got the theme
that was the issue i had with it was i
didn't feel like they needed to be
like so on the nose or wildly
expositional for us to get the theme of
the movie there was some expositional
stuff in in the first wonder woman to
get the themes down of the characters
and the learning lessons they're nowhere
near as ham-fisted and punched up as
they are
here which fits for an 80s movie at the
same time though uh
there was things about the way it was
handled of i feel like it's relying so
much on telling me and so i'm actually
not feeling it as much yeah
because there's so much monologuing to
the camera about this
and i'm just let me feel it for a second
show not tell everything you know yeah
and i feel like that's also a place
where the movie kind of gets
maybe split in who it's trying to aim at
too
because part of me was thinking and i
think it's absolutely fair to aim at
younger audiences because
superheroes were originally intended for
young people to read
for sure but yeah there are times in
which it feels like
it could be more sophisticated in just
showing us and giving us the credit
enough to understand what they're going
for instead of like matter-of-factly
making sure periodically we check back
in on the theme in case you forgot and i
feel like if you find yourself in a
position where you need to do that you
probably have a little too much going on
yeah
and the theme is really in conjunction
with the character of wonder woman
exploring like love compassion truth
all those qualities are are things that
are so in tune one word so
using this theme as a backdrop for the
characters of the movie and to try to
have those characters fulfill that where
cheetah feels very output
and how all the characters were built
but i had a great thing about
sisterhood there's something in there
come on i like the theme
i just uh i thought that there was parts
about
conveying that theme throughout that i
thought could have hit the feels a
little bit harder
that's about it yeah that's about it
olivia rogers i just want to
talk about this super brief how would
you describe the rules of the dream
stone i noticed touches of inconsistency
yeah i could i couldn't keep booming
back to steve trevor i couldn't get past
the fact of why didn't he just come back
from the dead
yeah how what forces in the universe
accounted for like oh can't have people
like disappearing or popping up we got
to keep the same number of people so
this guy's
i'm gonna transform because i'm like
[ __ ] just keeps appearing left and right
in this world like the guy with the cows
in the
like or or the wall like they're like
it's like inanimate objects are the
things that are able to appear
but people they can't just bring it back
like why does the soul take over this
person
and when things go back to normal like
certain debris remains
other debris just goes reverse and
disappears entirely
yeah yeah there was there were parts of
it that were a little bit
confusing to me and then to me this
whole thing with the dream stone kind of
ma it is one of those things that makes
me think about the dceu continuity
of all this crazy [ __ ] happened in 1984
is anything that's gonna ever be brought
up
or is everyone going to remember it like
an awful dream of some kind
i don't think i think they remember it
it's right certainly
yeah they didn't specify that nobody
remembers it and afterwards i mean yeah
especially on that last moment between
wonder woman and that that guy yeah it
certainly seems as though
he was at least and the rest of the
world was affected in the aftermath
and just to clarify i did see a few
people ask like why is it that
cheetah was able to get two wishes and i
thought the movie made that clear
he makes a wish uh people make a wish
and he gets something in return he
declares what he wants in return and in
the midst of that
teleprompter telecasting that he was
doing he said in return give her
the rage and aggression she desires so
he like converted one of his in returns
to give to her god
yeah okay that makes more sense because
they do at one point say something like
you know you
you get one wish no she even questions
it so he
used it to his advantage yeah it's in
the return and pointed and i
i feel like that can go over people's
heads but i thought the movie
did have a line of dialogue that was
like okay that's where it is
at first i was worried at the end when
the kid was like i wished you'd come
back and i knew you would and i was like
when did you do that though
because what if this is just a symptom
of the thing all over again
i mean she said he said his his actual
wish was i wish i could have your
greatness your greatness yeah but does
that
come into the fold here i don't i
thought that was he was gonna represent
some greater side of him or something or
like become evil
no just take all of the good parts of
maxwell lord that's making him even more
bitter but that's what i mean it's like
what
they didn't do anything with that wish
it seemed like such a high stakes moment
of like okay what did this what did this
kids wish
power from yeah did this mess things up
you know but it didn't do anything
didn't affect
anything no that's i mean it's a it's a
real plot hole
yeah it's a real flaw with the movie
yeah let's send it off with this
might as well save the post credit scene
for the for the end
how do we feel about the after credit
scene like to hear your opinions um
well i mean that's the scene where linda
carter you they reveal she's hysteria
and you was gonna be linda carter
obviously not gallagher it's gonna be
linda bring it in from the girl from the
pilot that didn't get picked up
but then to do the asteria character i
was like oh
sweet that's cool it was her then i just
throw it up a bunch of questions
she's abandoning everyone after that
she's just chilling on planet earth just
incognito
she just left she's like does she know
where the armor is
exactly she boba fett now like what the
hell's going on yeah
part three she's going to turn up she's
going to be like
[Laughter]
that's what we have to look forward to
and then they can have some kind of
civil war
wonder women i mean the fact that the
easter egg of if you don't know
it's linda carter like some people i i
bet there are some people who don't know
like oh that's
that's who played wonder woman
originally if you don't know that it
probably
does not much for you because you
probably don't really care as much about
the hysteria character being there and
they didn't play it like an
ominous moment they played it like a fun
tongue-in-cheek easter egg yeah
um i was actually linda carter the whole
time but then in terms of plot i was
like are they gonna make this
they could open up the door for the
future of like wonder woman three you
have asteria and
wonder woman in a movie together and
that would be cool to get gal gadot and
linda carter
co-starring in a film together that
would be really cool to get the original
wonder woman in there
as a different person it just did open
up questions for me that
was like wait a minute she just
abandoned you just saved these two kids
who did you save during all this stuff
that just happened where were you were
you here
did you know were you on earth because
if you're on earth you must have known
anyway guys um yeah in conclusion
uh i thought it was all right
it's pretty all right that's all i've
enjoyed myself that's
that's my honest opinion i'm not trying
to ride
any even keel line here like when it was
done
i was like it was okay that's where i'm
at
it was okay it's got a lot of flaws but
the thing is
i wasn't waiting for it to end i wasn't
bored
and i wasn't annoyed and if you do any
of those qualities
because even though i do think the
film's a little too long which is
bizarre to me but
even if you do one of those quality if
one of those qualities i feel are really
like really resident for me bored
or annoyed then
i i'd probably be like really swinging
even like with cheetah finding her very
unnecessary
i still was not i was never bored and i
wasn't like waiting for it to end and in
fact there was a part of me that was a
little bummed when it was over
just because i'm like oh one of them's
over you know i had a lot of fun
everything that popped up whether it was
over or underutilized had something i
enjoyed about it so yeah i had a good
time and there were some moments where i
was
either having a really fun time or was
crying about something so i do
appreciate that even in an uneven
experience like this it still managed to
grip me with a few things that were very
potent and uh
and yeah i really liked the overall of
what they were going for with maxwell
lord quite a bit
yeah i was uh i didn't
i like i didn't feel much when i was
watching it but i was like
amused throughout that was the idea that
was it i was amused
but it wasn't everyone on earth is going
to take advantage of just like the
implications of that i mean
that is a great sequence and it's a
great that's a scary scenario
resolved by something that's super easy
barely an inconvenience
oh well that and that too i was like oh
so all you have to do is just say i i i
recapped my wish
and now there are no consequences i'm
like you don't have to go through it
i i must have missed that detail because
i was like oh you got to kill max with
the lord to stop this right you got to
kill maxwell lord
that's the conflict she has and i was
like oh he's got a sciatica back and
being that he is the originator of this
whole situation does the stone
show back up or is it just destroyed i
think it's just destroyed at this point
it messed up the whole thing all right
guys well wonder woman 1984 what'd you
think of the movie
leave your thoughts down below you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit the like button
if you liked our review hit the like
button if you disagree with us
hit the like button just because you
like hitting like buttons
see you guys soon happy new year
you